higher priced medications have been
shown to be associated with stronger
placebo effects now researchers have
shown that higher drug prices are also
associated with a stronger nocebo effect
the placebo effect means you feel
positive effects because you think you
are receiving treatment when you really
are the nocebo effect means you feel
negative side-effects because you think
you're receiving treatment when you
really are it basically this new study
shows that if you think a drug costs
more you might experience stronger
negative side effects to figure this out
the researchers designed two boxes one
blue and one orange they then asked
subjects to rate how expensively thought
a medicinal cream would be if it came in
the box the blue design was rated as
significantly more expensive then
another set of subjects were told the
cream in these boxes was designed to
reduce itchiness and that as a
side-effect the Green would increase
pain sensitivity the researchers told
participants in advance that the Queen
was expensive or not showed them the box
and then had them apply it then they
expose their arms to a slightly painful
heat stimulant people that thought they
had gotten the more expensive cream
reported more pain with the same heat
when compared with those on the cheap
receiving cream the researchers think
this happens because of the perception
that more expensive drugs are more
powerful and would therefore have
stronger side effects fMRI images of the
brains and upper spinal cords of
subjects showed that the increased
nocebo effect was correlated with more
activity in the prefrontal cortex
understanding the top-down and bottom-up
processing of pain in the body may one
day help to treat chronic pain and
understanding how nocebo and placebo
effects are increased and help
researchers design better
[Music]